something else we were supposed to do in
this segment we haven't done yet
this concept of receivers who make the
quarterback because with devante adams
yes he's very good but the quarterback
makes the receiver before we
finally pull the plug on this segment
are there names that come to mind for
you
we talked about jerry rice and joe
montana yesterday did rice make montana
did montana make rice
who are the receivers that make the
quarterbacks there aren't a ton of them
that you can point to and say
you could put any quarterback on the
field and this guy's going to be good
with that receiver no you're you're
right and i mean a lot of the times it
was
you know like again yeah would i say
it's more rice than montana yeah i would
but it wasn't like montana with some
slouch or something like that
so all right so yeah you're right it's
hard actually when you come and come to
it
to that like like in the nfl right now
i mean it's hard to find that guy right
now as you talk about like a receiver
that makes a quarterback
alan robinson is probably the guy that
jumps out to me the most right he's like
had thousand yard receiving receiving
seasons with
you know trubisky and nick foles and all
these other issues
but like through time i'm gonna go
tyrell owens he's one that probably
jumps out there right for a guy that
more times than not made his quarterback
rather than the other side
other way around i think your man randy
moss probably fits that much absolutely
right other than the years with brady
he's carrying the squad or carrying the
offensive
passing attack when he was a rookie in
1998 there was a sense that you could
put anyone out there who was capable of
throwing the ball down the field and
that guy would have had a great season
they started the year with
brad johnson and they showed great
promise
week two brad johnson breaks a leg in
comes randall cunningham randall
cunningham has a career
rebirth he'd been out of football
altogether in 1996 was back up in
minnesota in 97 98 he's an mvp
candidate why because he knew to look
over at randy moss
and when randy moss was single covered
he dropped back
and he you know cranked back the
catapult and let it fly and moss would
go get it
moss was the ultimate as long as you
have somebody who can get the ball in
the air right
he's going to make you look good because
he's got the speed
and he's got the ball skills the body
control the ability to adapt and adjust
to the ball on the fly where he's just
going to go get it no matter where it's
coming down so
moss was that guy yeah throughout his
vikings tenure and dante culpepper
ultimately was the beneficiary of it
from 2000 until
he uh he well until moss left after the
2004 season
but uh yeah moss without moss to me is
the ultimate receiver who made the
quarterback
yeah he's he's i think you might be
right he's up there i'll give you
another one that i think's a real good
one that kind of like slips through the
cracks every now and then
andre johnson right with that
combination with matt schaub
you know again matt shop had a great
career i would love to have his career
i'm just saying like man andre johnson
was a stud he's one of the greatest of
all time
he definitely made more of that you know
relationship
than than vice versa that's another one
that jumps out to me
through the the test of time you know
tim brown
other than his like rich ganon years i
mean
who else was he really you know he was
never a part of like a really awesome
machine offense or anything like that
i'd sit there and say he could be one of
those guys you could kind of like
throw into that category that hey he
could get open and kind of make a
quarterback look good no matter what
especially in his prime
uh but yeah that's few and far between
steve largent
he might even fall in that category if
you look at it just top receivers all
time just the fact that he doesn't have
a quarterback
you can really staple to his name right
other than you know the old uh jim zorn
yeah zorn exactly right i was thinking
the old lefty coach i couldn't think of
his name right
right hey hey how about how about this
though yeah how about the guy
who caught passes from matt shaw brian
hoyer tom savage case keenum tj yates
ryan fitzpatrick brandon whedon aj
mccarran ryan mallett brock osweiler and
finally deshaun watson that's how about
deandre hopper oh
you know you're right you're right it's
i i that's
the the obvious one it's because we have
recent memory of him and watson together
but you're right the rest of that
ain't that good he was making the
offense and the receiver
he might be the biggest example of right
now
and hey i'll say odell early in his
career
hear what he was doing surprised i'm
surprised you don't have a song for
odell beckham jr i'm surprised it took
you this long into the conversation to
mention him well
i know it hurts he hasn't played in a
while i mean i
i need him to play and then i'll come up
with a song that's usually how it
happens i watch highlights and i get
happy
and i start humming songs and that's how
i come to these
stupid things i do i don't know and yeah
come on obj i need you out there let's
go
well odell beckham's gotten it done with
the giants and we've seen flashes with
the browns and if he gets healthy we may
see more than flashes because that
offense is getting better and better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports